veamos cómo formar y minas y en láminas
empecemos con la formación de una mina
tenemos un aldehído acetona y agregamos
una lámina también necesitamos un
catalizador ácido sí que es igual a un
nitrógeno o un grupo al kilo que sería
una rb prima entonces formaremos una
mina también formaremos agua si queremos
cambiar el equilibrio hacia la derecha
necesitamos eliminar el agua al momento
que se forme así obtendremos más
cantidad de mina
echemos un vistazo al mecanismo de las y
minas les presentaré dos formas y
ustedes podrán elegir la que quieran
usar una forma sería con la presencia de
un ácido pongamos un ácido general h a
más
esto protón hará a nuestra amina
un par de electrones libres en este
oxígeno tomará este protón dejando estos
electrones dibujemos el resultado de
esto ahora tenemos a nuestro oxígeno con
una carga formal positiva aquí tenemos
el grupo r prima sigamos a los
electrones estos electrones tomaron a
este protón y formaron este enlace en
vídeos anteriores
dijimos que al protón ar el oxígeno este
carbono se vuelve más electro físico así
que este carbono es un buen electro filo
y la mina será un buen núcleo filo un
par de electrones libres en el nitrógeno
atacará a este carbono empujando estos
electrones hacia el oxígeno dibujemos el
resultado
ahora tenemos a nuestro nitrógeno
formando un enlace con el carbono
resaltemos estos electrones en azul este
par de electrones libres forman un
enlace entre el nitrógeno y el carbono
esto le da al nitrógeno una carga formal
positiva y nuestro carbono está unido a
este oxígeno estos electrones se
quedaron con el oxígeno y el carbono
sigue unido a los grupos al kilo r&r
prima esta es una forma de empezar el
mecanismo pero existe otra esta vez
usamos directamente el nitrógeno como
núcleo filo la mina es muy buena como
núcleo filo de este lado tenemos un
oxígeno con una carga parcial negativa
y un carbono con una carga parcial
positiva
este es nuestro electro filo un par de
electrones libres en el nitrógeno ataca
directamente a este carbono empujando
estos electrones hacia el oxígeno
dibujemos el resultado de esto ahora
tenemos a nuestro carbono unido al
nitrógeno que a su vez está unido a dos
hidrógenos y a un grupo y lo que le da
al nitrógeno una carga formal positiva
después tenemos a nuestro oxígeno con
una carga formal negativa y abajo
tenemos a nuestros grupos al kilo
sigamos a los electrones si el nitrógeno
ataca directamente estos electrones
forman este enlace y estos electrones se
quedan con el oxígeno
este es nuestro intermediario pero para
que podamos llegar al que ya habíamos
visto
necesitamos protón ar el oxígeno con la
carga formal negativa entonces dibujemos
un ácido general por aquí h
más un par de electrones libres toma el
protón dejando a los electrones esto nos
da el mismo intermediario que teníamos
antes así que pueden empezar su
mecanismo por cualquiera de las dos
formas una vez que lleguen a este
intermediario podemos pensar en la base
este par de electrones toma un protón
dejando estos electrones con el
nitrógeno dibujemos lo que nos quedaría
hemos de protón ado y formamos esta
estructura el carbono está unido al
nitrógeno y unidos al nitrógeno aún
tenemos un grupo iv y un hidrógeno tiene
un par de electrones libres estos
electrones en morado se quedaron en el
nitrógeno y de este lado unidos al
carbono tenemos un grupo o h y nuestros
grupos alquilo r&r prima este
intermediario se llama carbono la mina
lo escribiré
carbinol
amina
para el siguiente paso podemos protón ar
el grupo h así que nuevamente tenemos un
ácido general h a más y un par de
electrones libres en el oxígeno toma un
protón dejando estos electrones
entonces si proponemos la carr vino la
mina nos queda un carbono aquí un
hidrógeno acá un par de electrones
libres nuestro grupo y un hidrógeno los
grupos al kilo y como protón amos el h
hemos formado agua que es un buen grupo
saliente y tenemos una carga formal
positiva en este oxígeno sigamos a los
electrones este par de electrones libres
en el oxígeno tomaron este protón
formando este enlace y como pueden ver
tenemos una molécula de agua que es un
buen grupo saliente entonces si estos
electrones se van junto con el oxígeno
estos electrones en el nitrógeno se
moverán para formar un doble enlace
en nuestro siguiente paso perdemos agua
menos h2o y ahora tenemos a nuestro
carbono unido con un doble enlace al
nitrógeno el nitrógeno sigue unido al
grupo iv y a un hidrógeno el nitrógeno
tiene una carga formal positiva y el
carbono sigue unido a los grupos al kilo
sigamos a los electrones estos
electrones en rosa de nuestro nitrógeno
se movieron para formar este doble
enlace entre el carbono y el nitrógeno
esta es una estructura muy importante
que se llama jon y niño
perdimos agua y llegamos al ion y niño y
para llegar al producto final solo
necesitamos es protón ar el guión y niño
entonces este par de electrones tomará
este protón dejando estos electrones en
el nitrógeno nos queda este carbono
unido con un doble enlace a nuestro
nitrógeno y por aquí tenemos a nuestros
grupos al kilo sigamos a los electrones
estos electrones en azul se quedaron en
el nitrógeno y recuerden que si la aie
es un hidrógeno o un grupo alquiló esta
es la formación de una mina veamos un
ejemplo empezaremos con un acetona
ciclohexano y la hacemos reaccionar con
una lámina primaria el nitrógeno está
unido
a un carbono y como catalizador usaremos
ácido sulfúrico para llegar al producto
de esta reacción tiene que ocurrir un
mecanismo muy largo pero solo veremos
una parte sabemos que el núcleo filo
será nuestra amina y atacara a este
carbono también sabemos que durante el
mecanismo perdemos un protón digamos que
será este protón también perdemos agua
menos h2o así llegamos hasta el paso del
ion y niño entonces tenemos nuestro
anillo
y como ya perdimos agua ahora tenemos al
nitrógeno con un doble enlace y el
nitrógeno tiene un grupo estilo por aquí
y un protón por acá lo que le da una
carga formal positiva
este es nuestro ion y niño para el
último paso sabemos que una lámina entra
y funcionará como una base este par de
electrones en el nitrógeno tomarán al
protón dejando estos electrones
dibujemos el producto
tenemos el doble enlace y el nitrógeno
por aquí tenemos al grupo de tilo y un
par de electrones libres estos
electrones en azul se quedaron en el
nitrógeno para formar nuestra mina
entonces cuando aún tenemos un protón
aquí estamos hablando del ior y niño y
la de explotación es el último paso para
formar una mina esto lo hicimos con una
mina primaria ahora hablemos de la
formación de en láminas el mecanismo
para la formación de una mina inicia de
la misma forma pero cambia un poco en el
paso del lyon y niño echemos un vistazo
a esta reacción de una acetona con una
lámina secundaria no veremos todo el
mecanismo pero veamos qué sucede
rápidamente
sabemos que el núcleo filo atacará justo
y también perderemos un protón este es
el único protón que nos falta perder
también perderemos agua dibujemos el
johnny niño que nos queda aquí tenemos a
nuestro anillo y tenemos el nitrógeno
con un doble enlace ya perdimos el
protón en rojo así que ahora sólo
tenemos dos grupos al kilo y una carga
formal positiva en la reacción anterior
regresemos un poco aquí en el johnnie
niño teníamos un protón que podíamos
perder en el paso de la des protón
acción pero en este caso no tenemos un
hidrógeno unido al nitrógeno así que no
podemos de protón ar aquí sin embargo
tenemos un hidrógeno en uno de los
carbonos adyacentes aquí tenemos un
protón una base entra dibujar en nuestra
amina
y este par de electrones toma este
protón empujando estos electrones hacia
aquí y estos electrones se moverán hacia
el nitrógeno dibujemos el producto ahora
tenemos un doble enlace justo aquí y
luego tenemos el nitrógeno unido a estos
grupos de tilo con un par de electrones
libres
sigamos algunos electrones estos
electrones son los que se movieron para
formar el doble enlace y estos
electrones se fueron con el nitrógeno
esta es una en amina lo escribiré
en la mina en se refiere a la parte del
doble enlace y amina se refiere a esta
parte así que tenemos una en amina la
formación de una en amina ocurre porque
no tenemos el mismo yo ni niño que
teníamos antes porque empezamos con una
amina secundaria por eso es muy
importante reconocer el tipo de amina
con el que reaccionará su aldehído
acetona si es una amina secundaria
formarán una en amina hablaremos más
sobre esto en los siguientes vídeos pero
recuerden que el mecanismo no cambia
hasta que lleguen al último paso